nevada governor steve sisilak honoring
former eight news now anchor paulie
gonzalez as part of women's history
month in a tweet yesterday he recognized
her time spent mentoring young hispanic
students interested in careers in
journalism as you may remember paulie
was an award-winning journalist here at
channel 8 and the first latina evening
news anchor in nevada she died in a car
accident the day after easter in 2005
leaving behind two daughters who
survived the crash
that's sabrina and gabriella
i just talked to sabrina last night we
are very much in touch and very close to
the girls
and i
i just have a hard time believing that
that was 2005.
um it seems like paulie was right here
on the set yesterday and uh the time
passes really way too fast although the
girls were much younger and they're
growing up now what are they 20
something they're in their 20s they just
turned 25 and 22
and graduating from college wow but
leaving a beautiful legacy and then
having the governor recognize her and
all of her hard work yeah and she's
remembered quite often here in las vegas
and i'm so glad and there's probably not
a week that goes by that somebody
doesn't ask me
about the girls or mention paulie's name
and comes up you know sometimes out of
the blue but it's really a wonderful
thing that she's not forgotten and nice
that the governor recognized that online
as well
for